speak more about this trans situation
women you know who needs to speak up
more about this Chelsea Handler boss
babe I don't need no man no thing I
don't need no kids mothers I'm a woman
let's see if I agree claims to have a
gynecologist part of it is I just
actually went to the gynecologist it's
never particularly Pleasant the exam
doesn't feel particularly good the pap
smear is very uncomfortable
so magnet foxes are not Megan Fox Megan
Kelly is hot what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in let's get started so today I am going
to be reacting to uh Megyn Kelly
blasting the trans Community women need
to speak up I'm a woman let's see if I
agree why is it making my blood boil
that Kristen claims to have a
gynecologist part of it is I just
actually went to the gynecologist it's
never particularly Pleasant the exam
doesn't feel particularly good the pap
smear is very uncomfortable oh thank you
Megan thank you also Megan Fox's are not
Megan Fox Megan Kelly is hot that she's
like in her 40s she looks so good you
know I don't even really think she's at
work done like that she looks so good
anyways but yes yes why do we have men
pretending to have gynecologist this is
just craziness crazy no one looks
forward to that we actually have things
we need to worry about like ovarian
cancer things that are particular to
that exam and that relationship that no
man is ever going to have all right so
that guy doesn't have a gynecologist
that guy has a hole that a surgeon
created at best there are things that
make women special and there are things
that we've overcome and that we must
overcome as women in order to thrive in
them in this life whether it's the
threat of sexual violence or you know
being attacked as we walk home from
college bars to our dorms the fears that
you have when you go to the gynecologist
I mean honestly Megan I gotta say I'm
with you on this whole trans thing but I
don't think women really fear walking
home Home Alone from college bars
because we do it half naked at four in
the morning by our damn selves I swear
if you go into any college town there
there is no woman where I swear that is
afraid because if they were I don't
think they'd be half naked at 4am but
you know that's that's another convo I
know I'm signed tracking those things
they're baked in and it's part of what
makes women so incredible and strong and
you can't just become one and take all
of our things because you did or did not
have a surgery or you put on a dress
it's that's facts that's facts doesn't
work like that spoke like a true woman I
love this I love her let me tell you how
necessary a voice like Megan Kelly is
right now in this insane situation where
you know who and Megan Kelly
time off of her career for a couple
years to raise a family because a lot of
you'll see a lot of the conservative
pundits kind of like even when they have
a family it's very clear that they don't
at their career is first before their
kids not back in Cali that woman's
badass she was like no I don't care if
I'm an anchor on Fox News I'm gonna go
raise my children to speak more about
this trans situation women you know who
needs to speak up more about this
Chelsea Handler boss babe I don't need
no man no thing I don't need no kids
mothers okay you know who it is about
the feminization of men and these [__]
boys that this that were creating this
toxic masculinity women that like real
men and someone like Megan Kelly I think
represents all of that and then some and
her voice is very necessary I agree and
well maybe we get around but ask you a
question why is it that it's just this
is my it's my opinion as much as you
know you well as much as you say that
then why is it that more women like
Chelsea Handler are turned on by you
yeah they love oh they love that you
know why
[Music]
I agree with you I 100 agree with her
but is it just me or or are we just
seeing the voices that are sticking up
for these people it's only from the
right the left they can't even Define
yeah it's like all the the liberal
chicks it's like men are invading our
locker rooms they're invading our Sports
they're invading women's spaces and it's
like we're all these Pro women these Pro
women group it's like be Pro women